[Music]
my favorite part of this marvel intro to
a hawkeye show is that you have to play
a game of where's clinto to even locate
him he flashes in the m here for like
half a second and this is his [ __ ]
show living in the past i'm sure they're
there but in this shot i can't see the
hind legs of this giraffe which makes me
think of how a two-legged giraffe would
basically look like a really tall person
without arms and with a horse face and
spotted fur but my point is two-legged
giraffe mommy said things don't just
fall from the sky well blow out your
marvel reference bingo card cause you
can mark off invasion of new york on it
we're only two minutes in and i'm
already just the people disappeared in
the blip and a free space away from
calling bingo i bet she didn't know i
could do this
impressing your children with a choking
hazard this bisected narwhal why are all
the animals in this room terrifying me
daddy where are you well she literally
just said okay i'm going i'll start so
maybe start there okay so i've been
working on this new impression and this
seems as good a time as any to try it
out
generic bad guy soldiers whose abilities
and shortcomings are never explained
nailed it attempting to make hawkeye
look cool i'm still the luckiest woman
in the world
because i have the greatest little girl
in the world and you didn't seem to like
your husband very much and were weirdly
jealous of the bond he and kate had so
winning one minute and 29 seconds of
opening titles we're watching kate train
in this opening but did you see how
quickly those two arrows hit that target
the only way she's firing off arrows
that accurately and that quick at this
point in her training is if someone
skull matrixed archery directly into her
wait is that blood spatter if you're
getting blood spatter from a strike
you're fencing wrong present day come on
guys we've been through this if i watch
this 40 years from now will it take
place in 2061 unless of course you're
playing into the christmas theme and
mean present day which honestly is still
too vague so merry christmas here's your
present if you get caught you're
definitely gonna be kicked off the
archery team which brings the question
why are they on the phone right now
kate's friends can see her up there and
them being on the phone doesn't change
what she's going to do probably isn't
anyone that will hear them talking this
late at night but why take a chance plus
kate left her coat discarded on the
stairs so i'm pretty sure covert is on
top of the ring the bell raid bet
priority list i know she's an expert
archer and all that comes with it but
i'm still giving this a this works
because just like the dennis leary song
says i'm an [ __ ]
yo yo
alright that's uh that's not great no
it's not but honestly if the weight of
your little tennis bald arrow is doing
this that bell was a stiff breeze away
from pulling a full hunchback and notre
damning itself anyway
setting your action series at christmas
time without shane black involved iron
man 3 wasn't that bad i mean
yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but also episode does not contain rogers
the musical in its entirety honey i know
i know what happens talking during a
live performance
why is the shawarma visit even mentioned
in this musical it seems like the
musical referencing the movie we saw not
the actual events as they happened in
this world you're telling me the
avengers casual dining experience at
schwarma somehow made headlines enough
that it's a key punchline in this song
reading while peeing keep your attention
on the job at hand so i don't have to
step in your unsupervised flonin k clint
also why is thanos lowercase but right
is capitalized getting the grammar
correct is the first rule of urinal
graffiti if you can't do it right don't
do it at all kids
this whole thing is a bit ridiculous
isn't it still can't believe he was an
avenger would be excellent at tv sins
why is everyone singing and dancing
about everything musicals vera farmiga
isn't ghost hunting in this scene i'm
about to replace an irreplaceable clock
tower but if it's irreplaceable then how
will you replace it do words mean
nothing anymore we cannot be late so
go change
meet us at the hotel and we'll talk
there okay i haven't actually told you
the hotel we'll be at but i'm sure if
you get in the cab and ask for the hotel
the rich people are at they'll know
exactly where to take you mom is going
say hi putting your phone on speaker in
a public place no one else wants to hear
your conversation hawkeye no one
christmas movie marathon i'm sitting
christmas movie marathons for
necessitating conversations on what
constitutes a christmas movie you know
what i've decided there's no such thing
as a christmas movie there are movies
that take place around christmas movies
that mention christmas and maybe even
movies you like to watch around
christmas i'm half tempted to start a
debate about what movies are thursday
movies just to show you all how
ridiculous you sound it's necessary
you're safe in our city and put us in
financial ruin for the next few years
with all the destruction you helped
cause but we ignore that bart
hi heck of a party huh
rude dogs sure is nice of people in
shows and movies to leave doors wide
open when they're talking about stuff so
our characters can get the info they
need it's so against human nature yet
they manage it every time also between
this scene and the one at the beginning
i hope kate's superhero name ends up
being the eavesdropper cause that is
definitely a power she wields lucky for
kate she has on the exact same suit the
wait staff is wearing at the event how
else would she accomplish the worst
infiltration attempt ever why don't we
leave eleanor alone your goat i don't
know if mustachio here ends up being a
bad guy or not but if he is then here's
a sin for the show making it this
obvious however if jack ends up not
being a bad guy then here's a sin for
the show making it this obvious and not
following through
you heard me we have four champagne
glasses we don't have four champagne
glasses another important conversation
she just happens to find kate
accidentally herself into plot relevant
information like she's the bow and arrow
version of inspector freaking clouseau
come on ladies and gentlemen this sword
belonged to the infamous ronin but that
would be nearly impossible to prove
right i'm no auction expert but i'm
guessing proof is important when
assessing the value let's go
and the director said he's wearing a
mask so the apple's probably out but
let's have him say the word bro it will
accomplish the same thing case
conveniently clears its contents for
kate to cleverly clothe her core
conspicuously do you know who i am
cliche
missing only exists in case you ever
wondered what the movie cocktail would
have looked like if marvel directed it
if the character lifts masks so we can
recognize them later even though there's
no practical reason to do so wasn't
enough show has his buddies yell out his
name for a double portion of audience
spoon feeding it's a little late for tv
guys i've got a pack but dad
how would we get in the blatant news
position without it on huh dad huh
cutting to the worst scene from avengers
end game well except there was that
scene where the hulk was eating a lot of
food and that scene where thor had a
beer gut and fine cutting to a top 10
worst scene from avengers in game are we
all ready to admit in game wasn't that
good i look forward to the pleasant
enlightening discussions that will be
happening in the comments section
welcome to my apartment having an
apartment in new york city when you
already have a dorm room on campus the
sin as always is rich kids
you like pizza that sound you just heard
it was the internet yelling pizza dog
because it's from the comics and by
internet i mean a few people that
actually knew the reference and then 100
times that many people who just heard
about it on twitter and want to pretend
it's meaningful to them as well so they
don't feel left out also feeding a dog
pizza but then giving him no water
monogrammed butterscotch kate doesn't
get kicked out of her school even though
she destroyed a historical bell tower
but wants to bark at armon's choices on
how he promotes his privilege pot
calling something something kate
did you see how badly she missed him
there slow that down so we can all
marvel at it
she's a good foot and a half from his
face how do you even include this shot
why doesn't she keep running i was
getting in a car with no key to start it
helpful at all in this scenario
ex hawkina
come on being this upset you can't hit
someone
you're out of your mind yeah
ain't it cool
you shouldn't use rob i want to know who
i'm looking at what did you say
but she didn't know i could do this
better tennis playing in a tampon
commercial
hello
pardon who
you're the little bishop girl what did
you call me
i called you your name
the hell you did i'm sorry i'm sorry you
found out this way no no mom this is
this is just like
fast sex is a serious thing norman i
thought i was supposed to be the only
one working here well you're wrong
what's your name
i'm an old soul i like old music and old
movies and all even old people